- Il n'y a plus que des piétons
sur le pont Simon Bolivar,
le pont le plus fréquenté entre
le Venezuela et la Colombie.
Plus d'autos, le commerce et
la contrebande réduits
au minimum.
Des contrôles de plus en plus
stricts.
Une ambiance de guerre froide.
50 000 Vénézuéliens traversent
le pont vers la Colombie tous
les jours. 5000 d'entre eux
ne reviendront plus. Ce sont
ceux qui ont des bagages,
valises ou sacs à dos.
Ils quittent le chômage,
une hyperinflation de près
d'un million pour cent,
la misère, la faim, les pénuries
de vivres et de médicaments.
Beaucoup d'entre eux font
la queue une ou deux fois
par jour à la Casa de Paso
de la Divine Providence,
où ils reçoivent des repas.
Le Padre David gère
les opérations avec
une précision presque
militaire : 900 volontaires et
employés d'ONG internationales
préparent des repas complets,
de très bonne qualité qui, pour
des Vénézuéliens, sont devenus
impossibles à obtenir.
- Ils gagnent 3 $ par mois chez
eux. Ici, on leur sert un repas
complet qui vaut 3 $.
- Pour combien de personnes
chaque jour?
- 4000.
4000 tous les jours,
sauf le dimanche.
- Derrière chacun des visages
de chaque famille, de chaque
personne, se cache un drame.
Parfois une tragédie.
Jose Luis Pachano est en route
pour le Pérou. Il était
chirurgien à l'hôpital
universitaire clinique
de Caracas. En 2015,
ses collègues et lui sont
remplacés par des "médecins
communautaires" et
des chirurgiens cubains
par le gouvernement Maduro.
En novembre, sa fille est
atteinte d'un cancer. Elle part
se faire soigner au Pérou,
faute de traitement
au Venezuela.
Hier, on lui annonce la mort
de sa fille.
Il doit s'occuper
des funérailles et il compte
rester au Pérou définitivement.
Plus question de retourner
au Venezuela.
Son épouse est enceinte.
Avant de passer les frontières,
des bandits vénézuéliens
leur ont tout volé : argent
et papiers. Ils vont chercher
de l'aide auprès des ONG.
Cette frontière a toujours été
très ouverte, mais autrefois,
il n'y a pas si longtemps,
ce sont les Colombiens
qui allaient se réfugier
au Venezuela pour fuir
la violence de la guérilla,
des paramilitaires et aussi
pour trouver du travail
parce que le Venezuela était
le pays le plus riche d'Amérique
du Sud avec son pétrole.
Maintenant, c'est l'inverse
qui se produit et on assiste
à une crise migratoire
sans précédent en Amérique.
La Colombie à son tour rend
service. Mais c'est un poids
énorme : chaque mois,
100 000 Vénézuéliens débarquent.
100 000 personnes, c'est
l'équivalent d'une bonne ville
moyenne. Ce qui vient avec plus
de criminalité, une concurrence
déloyale dans le commerce
et, depuis l'an dernier,
on parle d'un phénomène
qui s'appelle xénophobie.
Mais sans trop de violence
jusqu'ici.
Il n'y a pas de camps
de réfugiés en Colombie :
les autorités ne l'ont pas
permis pour éviter de trop
fortes concentrations.
Les migrants doivent quitter
la région et ils le font souvent
à pied.
Cette famille a quitté Caracas
et s'en va vers Cali.
Des gens en auto leur ont donné
de la nourriture.
Ils s'apprêtent à repartir.
Ils sont mal équipés. Cali est
à plus de 900 kilomètres.
Un millier de personnes
prennent la route ainsi
tous les jours. À cette halte,
ils laissent des messages
sur des billets de banque qui ne
valent plus rien. Des messages
de foi et d'espoir.
On veut aussi laisser la trace
de son passage.
Certains messages s'en prennent
au président Nicolas Maduro.
Celui-ci dit : "Notre pays a été
détruit grâce à la révolution
de Maduro et ses voleurs
corrompus et ses misérables
militaires. Un jour, ils vont
payer."
Puis ils reprennent la route
vers les montagnes.
Ils ne le savent peut-être pas,